we can be here as a campaign that DC
Comics and warner brothers entertainment
have joined forces to to provide relief
for the people in the Horn of Africa who
are suffering the worst famine in 60
years so when Jim Lee called me and
asked if I wanted to be involved I was
like absolutely I just don't know what
we can do it what what does that look
like so we kind of sat down and did some
brainstorming and I was like wait a
minute I have a song on our album break
the spell called rescue me that I
thought lyrically could really work for
the campaign and so what we did is we
went back and rear accorded it stripped
it down made it more acoustic piano bass
and just put it on iTunes this week so
every time someone downloads that
version one hundred percent of those
proceeds goes to the famine relief and I
also did a piece of original art or with
with Jim Lee for the darkness and light
exhibit that will be touring the world
for two years to raise awareness and and
I think the hope is to raise two million
dollars in this 2-year period and all
the artwork is up for auction all this
money that's being raised goes towards
these organizations that are providing
the proper resources to these locations
and so with us raising awareness to our
fans and getting the word out there on
iTunes and on our website and then DC
Comics doing their part we hope that
with everyone getting involved every
little bit can help and be a success
it's not like a natural disaster or a
tsunami or something that you hear about
on the news it's literally drought and
fam
and it's something that we can do that
that I at least the way I perceive that
it seemed like there was light at the
end of the tunnel get them food get them
water problem solved so simply text the
word heroes the number will be on the
website up early and every time you do
that money goes towards the cause every
time you download rescue me the we can
be heroes version same thing and there's
other ways that are on DC comics com and
dr. official that have linked to that
have all the details where you can go we
hope that with everyone getting involved
every little bit can help and be a
success